and so you had a text-based web browser
yeah uh well actually the original
browser Tim berners-lee the original the
original browser both the original
browser and the server actually ran on
next next cubes so these were this was
you know the computer Steve Jobs made
during the interim period when he during
the decade-long interim period when he
was not an apple you know he got fired
in 85 and then came back in 97 so this
was in that interim period where he had
this company called Next and they made
these literally these computers called
cubes and there's a statement story they
were beautiful but they were 12 inch by
12 inch by 12 inch cubes computers and
there's a famous story about how they
could have cost half as much if it had
been 12 by 12 by 13 but
he was like no like it has to be so they
were like six thousand dollar basically
academic workstations they had the first
CD-ROM drives
um yeah which were slow I mean it was
the computers were all but unusable um
they were so slow but they were
beautiful okay can we actually just to
take a tiny tangent there sure of course
the the 12 by 12 by 12. uh they just so
beautifully encapsulated Steve Jobs idea
of design can you just comment
on um what you find interesting about
Steve Jobs What uh about that view of
the world that dogmatic pursuit of
perfection in how he saw Perfection and
Design
yes I guess they say like look he was a
deep believer I think in a very deep the
way I interpret it I don't know if you
ever really described it like this but
the way it interpret it is it's like
it's like this thing and it's
essentially a thing in philosophy it's
like Aesthetics are not just appearances
Aesthetics go all the way to like deep
underlining underlying meaning right
it's like
I'm not a physicist one of the things
I've heard of physicists to say is one
of the things you start to get a sense
of when a theory might be correct is
when it's beautiful right like you know
they're right and so so so there's
something and if you feel the same thing
by the way in like human psychology
right you know when you're experiencing
awe right you know there's like a
there's like a there's a Simplicity to
it when you're having an interaction
with somebody there's an aesthetic I
would say calm it comes over you because
you're actually being fully honest and
trying to hide yourself right so they're
so so it's like this very deep sense of
Aesthetics and he would trust that
judgment that he had to deep down like
even even if the engineering teams are
saying this is uh this is too difficult
even if the whatever the finance folks
are saying this is ridiculous the uh the
supply chain all that kind of stuff
stuff this makes this impossible number
two we can't do this kind of material
this has never been done before and so
on and so forth he just sticks by it
well I mean who makes the phone out of
aluminum right like
nobody else would have done that and now
of course if your phone is made out of
aluminum you know how crude what kind of
caveman would you have to be to have a
phone that's made out of plastic like
right so like so it's just this very
right and you know look it's it's
there's a thousand different ways to
look at this but one of the things
that's just like look these things are
Central to your life like you're with
your phone more than you're with
anything else like it's in your it's
going to be in your hand I mean he you
know you noticed he thought very deeply
about what it meant for something to be
in your hand all day long yeah but for
example
here's an interesting design thing like
he he never wanted it it's my
understanding is he never wanted an
iPhone to have a screen larger than you
could reach with your thumb one-handed
and so he was actually opposed to the
idea of making the phones larger and I
don't know if you have this experience
today but let's say there are certain
moments in your day when you might be
like only have one hand available um and
you might want to be on your phone yeah
if you're trying to like
after texting you your thumb can't reach
the send button yeah I mean there's pros
and cons right and then there's like
folding phones which I would love to
know what he thought it thinks about
them uh but I mean is there something
you could also just Ling on because he's
one of the interesting
um figures in the history of Technology
what makes him
what makes him as successful as he was
what makes him as interesting as he was
uh what made him
um so productive and important in um in
in the development of Technology he had
an integrated worldview so the the the
the properly designed device that had
the correct functionality that had the
deepest understanding of the user that
was the most beautiful right like it had
to be all of those things right it was
he basically would drive to as close to
perfect as you could possibly get right
and I I you know I suspect that he never
quite you know thought he ever got there
because most great creators you know are
generally dissatisfied you know you read
accounts later on and all they can all
they can see are the flaws in their
creation but like he got as close to
perfect each step of the way as he could
possibly get with the with the
constraints of the of the technology of
his time
um and then you know look he was you
know sort of famous in the Apple model
it's like look they they they will you
know this this headset that they just
came out with like it was like a decade
long
project right it's like and they're just
gonna sit there and tune and tune and
polish and polish and tune and polish
and tune and polish until it is as
perfect as anybody could possibly make
anything yeah and then this goes to the
the way that people describe working
with him was which is you know there was
a terrifying aspect of working with him
which is you know he was you know he was
very tough
um but there was this thing that
everybody I've ever talked to work for
him says that they all say the following
which is he we did the best work of Our
Lives when we worked for him because he
set the bar incredibly high and then he
supported us with everything that he
could to let us actually do work of that
quality so a lot of people who were at
Apple spend the rest of their lives
trying to find another experience where
they feel like they're able to hit that
quality bar again even if it in
retrospect or during it felt like
suffering yeah exactly
what does that teach you about the Human
Condition huh so look so I say exactly
so the Silicon Valley I mean look he's
not you know George Patton in the you
know in the Army like you know there are
many examples in other fields you know
that are like this
um uh uh
specifically in Tech it's actually I
find it very interesting there's the
Apple Way which is Polish Polish Polish
and don't ship until it's perfect
because you can make it and then there's
the sort of the other approach which is
the sort of incremental hacker mentality
which basically says ship early and
often and iterate and one of the things
I find really interesting is I'm now 30
years into this like
they're a very successful companies on
both sides of that approach right um
like that is a fundamental
difference right in how to operate and
how to build and how to create that you
have world-class companies operating in
both ways
um and I don't think the question of
like which is the superior model is
anywhere close to being answered like
and my suspicion is the answer is do
both the answer is you actually want
both they lead to different outcomes
software tends to do better
um with the iterative approach
um the hardware tends to do better with
the uh you know sort of wait and make it
perfect approach but again you can find
examples in in in both directions uh so
the jury's still out on that one